One of the things we talked about after
zero point zero Republicans in the House
or Senate voted for Joe Biden's one point
nine trillion dollars, covid relief bill was
will these Republican elected officials who voted
against the bill that even many Republican voters
wanted the covid relief bill, remember, had about
70 percent support. You don't get that with just
Democrats. That means independents and Republicans
as well. We wondered, will any of these Republican
elected officials suffer consequences as a result
of voting against that bill? And we quickly saw,
even though they all voted against it, some
Republicans publicly taking credit for the fact
that the bill was passed and actually saying it's
good that people are getting this or that or the
other thing. It's actually even worse than this.
A new poll finds that a third of Republican voters
believe that Republican lawmakers did vote for
the covid relief bill. Remember, nobody in not
a single Republican in the House voted in favor
of the covid relief bill a couple of weeks ago.
Not a single Republican in the Senate voted
in favor of the covid relief bill. One guy
in the Senate was missing. He didn't vote
one way or the other, not a single one.
And yet, Data for Progress and Vox conducted
a poll of Republican voters, and 53 percent
knew that their Republican lawmakers did not
vote for the bill. But 31 percent said, yeah,
they did vote for the bill and 17 percent
didn't know. That means that 48 percent of
Republicans either wrongly believed that
their elected officials voted for the
fourteen hundred dollar stimulus checks that most
of them are getting or simply didn't know one way
or the other. Now, you might say, well, this is
probably a problem on the left as well. It is, but
only to a fraction of a degree. Just 16 percent
of Democratic voters thought Republicans voted
in favor of it. Just 16 percent of independent
voters thought Republicans voted in favor of
the covid relief bill. So what you have if if
you're if the question you're trying to answer
is, will there be repercussions for
Republicans for voting against it?
The answer is probably not. Number one, because
the opportunity for repercussions is still almost
two years away in the 2022 election. And number
two, because a whole bunch of these Republicans
think that their elected officials did vote in
favor of the bill. And this is exactly why I said
there may not be that much of a political risk to
these Republicans for voting against because their
constituents still get the money even though they
voted against. When it's convenient, they can say,
I oppose the wasteful spending on fill
in the blank and then they can still get
themselves reelected because their voters are
completely clueless now as far as the voters go.
Is this surprising?
Not really, if you're
able to be bamboozled into thinking Donald Trump
can fix trade, immigration, health insurance,
income inequality, wage. I mean, if you got
tricked into that, then I could understand how
you would wrongly believe Republican senators
and members of the House voted for a bill they
didn't vote for. If you fell for Trump saying the
virus is just the flu and 15 cases will be zero
and the covid vaccine could give you covid and
masks are bad and don't work and a reflection of
suppression of freedom and all of this
other stuff as half a million people die,
if you can fall for that stuff, it's pretty
plausible to believe that you will just wrongly
assess whether your representative voted for
or against the KOVR-TV relief bill. That that's
not really surprising. If you fell for Biden's a
socialist, Biden takes over. We're not we're going
to have toilets. You have to flush 15 times and no
windows and no heat and no air conditioning. And
it's all going to be socialism and
communism if you fell for that.
This is like child's play.
This is this is like nothing.
So, of course, right wingers, mostly
about 50 50. They wanted the stimulus.
Most of them got it. Of course, since
most of the country qualified for the
fourteen hundred dollar checks, they gladly
accepted the free money that counts as
socialism when they're hearing about the things
that Joe Biden is going to do. And in the end,
many of them, a third of them and close to
half, if you include the ones who don't know,
think that their elected officials who
tried to prevent them from getting the money
actually helped them get it. It's absolutely
stunning stuff. And as I've said before,
when you don't even have an agreement as to not
what the facts are, but what facts are meaning,
what is a fact and what is an opinion when you
don't even have agreement there, an understanding
on that, people will fall for anything. And that
explains Donald Trump. And it explains so much
of what we've seen over the last five years in
thinking about the future of the Republican Party